Fortune Cookies Were Invented in Japan, Not
China
The commonly held notion that Fortune Cookies
were invented in China typically comes from
the fact that they are primarily served in
Americanized Chinese restaurants.
However, you will not find fortune cookies
in actual Chinese restaurants, nor will you
find historical records of a similar food
item in China.
The largest manufacturer of fortune cookies,
Wonton Food, based in New York, even once
tried to introduce fortune cookies to the
Chinese in the late 1980s.
After three years, they gave up, as they simply
weren’t a popular food item there.
Most people, who know they were not invented
in China, typically think they were invented
in America, which is reasonable enough, considering
they are primarily consumed in America.
This is closer to the truth, but still not
quite there.
The various people who are often credited
as having invented fortune cookies, in almost
all credible cases, were Japanese immigrants
to America.
Thus, fortune cookies are sometimes humorously
referred to as “A Chinese food invented
by the Japanese in America”.
As it turns out though, fortune cookies were
actually invented in Japan, which is probably
why there are so many credible stories of
Japanese immigrants in the early 20th century
supposedly “inventing” fortune cookies.
In fact, they simply brought them over from
Japan.
This fact was only proven a couple decades
ago in a discovery by researcher, Yasuko Nakamachi,
who encountered a fortune cookie-shaped cracker,
called a Tsujiura Senbei, made by hand in
a family bakery (Sohonke Hogyokudo), near
a Shinto shrine outside of Kyoto, Japan.
This “cracker”, not only looked like a
fortune cookie, it also contained a fortune,
called an “omikuji” (fortune slip), and
was traditionally sold in shrines and temples.
These crackers are cooked by pouring batter
into waffle-iron-like molds and then holding
the irons over coals.
While the cracker is still warm, little pieces
of paper containing a message are folded within.
This all lead to research on exactly when
these crackers first started being made, to
see if they predated when the fortune cookies
first started showing up in America.
One of the earliest documented definitive
references can be found in an 1878 image of
an apprentice baker making these fortune cookies
in a bakery.
Not only was the apprentice baker depicted
making these cookies, but he was making them
exactly as they were being made by the bakery
Nakamachi observed them being baked at outside
of Kyoto.
This image was found in the 19th century book
of stories, “Moshiogusa Kinsei Kidan”,
and pre-dates fortune cookies popping up in
America by about two to three decades.
Going back even further than that, there is
a reference in a book, from the early 19th
century, where a woman tries to placate two
other women with a cracker that contains a
fortune inside.
Interestingly, descendants of two of the first
bakeries to make fortune cookies, including
one that has been in operation for about a
century in America, still possess the original
black iron “kata” grills their ancestors
used.
These grills are nearly identical to the ones
being used by the bakeries outside of Kyoto
and which also mirror the one depicted in
the 1878 image of the apprentice baker.
So fortune cookies were brought to America
from Japan by Japanese immigrants.
How then did they end up in Americanized Chinese
food restaurants?
There are a few plausible theories out there,
but nobody knows for sure.
After World War II, it is well documented
that fortune cookies were almost exclusively
being served in Chinese restaurants in California.
From there, they spread to nearly all Chinese
restaurants in America and a few others in
Europe and South America.
According to fortune cookie makers from that
era, the spread from California to the rest
of America was instigated largely by soldiers
returning home from Pacific Theater of Operations
(PTO).
When soldiers went home, they requested fortune
cookies from their local Chinese restaurants,
like they had found in California, and thus
the spread.
Further, during WWII, over 100,000 people
who were of Japanese decent were locked up
in internment camps; among them were many
of the Japanese bakers who made fortune cookies.
Also, things associated with Japan, such as
Japanese restaurants, weren’t too favorably
thought of at the time.
So a combination of many of the Japanese restaurant
and bakery owners and workers being locked
up and the unpopularity of things associated
with Japan left fortune cookies to be primarily
found in Chinese restaurants by the soldiers.
This also created a vacuum in the manufacturing
of fortune cookies, as many of the Japanese
manufacturers of fortune cookies were in internment
camps.
Thus, many Chinese bakeries took over in the
production of fortune cookies.
Another theory is simply that the Japanese
bakers themselves were perfectly willing to
sell to any restaurant that wanted to buy.
Chinese cuisine typically doesn’t have any
dessert items, thus it is plausible that the
fortune cookie caught on more with Chinese
restaurants because it made for a nice cheap
dessert to add to the menu.
Also, in the early 19th century, many Japanese
immigrants opened Americanized-Chinese restaurants
as Americanized-Chinese cuisine tended to
be more popular than traditional and even
Americanized-Japanese cuisine to Americans.
Bonus Facts:
• Fortune cookies are typically made primarily
from flour, sugar, vanilla, butter, and oil.
The original Japanese version was made from
the same basic ingredients except they substituted
sesame for vanilla and miso for butter.
They were also traditionally much larger than
we see them today, even among the early versions
presented in America.
• The popular claimants to have been the
supposed “inventors” of the fortune cookie
include: Makoto Hagiwara, who was a Japanese
immigrant who oversaw the construction of
the Japanese Tea Garden in San Francisco.
Visitors to this garden were served fortune
cookies made by Benkyodo, a Japanese bakery,
as early as 1907.
Despite the fact that he purchased them from
the Benkyodo bakery, Makoto Hagiwara is often
given credit for inventing them.
Another claimant is Chinese immigrant David
Jung, founder of the Hong Kong Noodle Company
in Los Angeles.
He said he created them in 1918.
Unfortunately for him, there are documented
cases, such as Makoto Hagiwara, serving them
before that date, even besides the documented
instances in Japan before this.
In his story, he said he was concerned about
the plight of the poor he saw wondering near
his shop, so created the cookie with inspirational
messages, such as scripture, embedded inside
and gave them away to these poor for free,
to both feed them and help lift their spirits.
Probably the most credible claimant to be
the first to introduce fortune cookies to
America was Seiichi Kito, the founder of the
Fugetsu-do bakery, which is still in operation
today.
Kito said that he got the idea from the cookies
sold in Japanese temples which contained fortunes
and that he very slightly modified the Japanese
recipe to fit American tastes better.
He then proceeded to sell them to restaurants
and they caught on best among Chinese restaurants
in LA and San Francisco.
His story closely matches the results of the
recent research done by Nakamachi, which was
done after Kito’s death.
• The practice of putting paper with messages
on it inside food was actually fairly common
in certain regions in Japan at one time, particularly
in candies.
This practice was later abandoned as many
people would eat the candy or baked product
without knowing there was a piece of paper
with a message inside the food item.
• Until the 1940s, fortune cookies were
known as “fortune tea cakes”.
• Edward Louie invented the world’s first
fortune cookie folding machine, which allowed
fortune cookies to be massed produced for
the first time.
Before his invention, fortune cookies were
all folded by hand.
In the 1980s, Dr. Yongsik Lee invented the
world’s first fully automated fortune cookie
machine.
This machine works by pumping the batter into
small heated grills.
After a few minutes of baking the batter,
a fortune message is laid on top of the baked
batter.
Clamps then close the cookies and form the
shape of the fortune cookie.
After this, the cookies are cooled and then
packaged.
• Chop suey, which translates to “break
into many pieces”, is commonly held to be
a “Chinese” food invented in America.
However, this is incorrect.
It was invented in Taishan, which is a district
of Guangdong Province, China.
So it is a Chinese food invented in China…
oddly enough.